la verdad es que los seres humanos somos
un poco el producto de nuestra historia
en nuestro entorno inicial yo soy el
quinto hijo de una familia con diez
hijos y la entrada después de la
merienda me ha recordado el pasillo de
mi casa
y quizás por eso necesito estar al aire
libre
necesito inundar me de luz ambiental que
por cierto en valencia es increíble
y os habéis fijado cómo cambia cómo
cambian los colores de la luz
estos cambios de los colores que no
percibimos prácticamente
son fundamentales para nuestra vida
en las nuevas centrales del día como es
la luz es blanca o azul
nos inunda nos hace estar activos y por
la tarde
es roja
nuestra ropa nos invita a descansar
es decir durante millones y millones de
años los seres humanos hemos estado
inmersos en un ambiente que cambia del
día a la noche de una forma previsible
periódica y aproximadamente cada 24
horas y nosotros y el resto de los
animales y plantas nos hemos tenido que
acostumbrar que adaptar a estos cambios
y para ello hemos desarrollado unos
sistemas internos realmente son unos
relojes internos unos relojes internos
que son automáticos y que
aproximadamente cada 24 horas
en realidad del nuestro lo hace cada
24,2 horas cicla y nos dice más o menos
a qué hora estamos con respecto a
nuestro ambiente pero como ciclo cada
24,2 horas necesita unos relojeros
externos que lo pongan cada día en hora
el relojero más importante ya hemos
visto son estos cambios en la proporción
de los colores de la luz
pero hay otros
otros relojeros externos quizás el más
importante después de la luz es como no
la pancha
cuando comemos es como sobrevivimos
comiendo y durante miles y millones de
años por la noche la comíamos
de tal manera que cuando comemos le dice
al cerebro si estás comiendo
probablemente y está esta luz es esta
hora hora del desayuno de la merienda
y otros relojeros tenemos
durante años no había otra por la noche
era oscuro hacía frío no nos activamos
nos arropamos en la cuna pues si salimos
a hacer running a las 10 de la noche
cuando yo era joven era correr después
footing hará running pero bueno esto no
importa
si salimos le estamos diciendo al
cerebro
joven si está corriendo es que es por la
mañana para ir a trabajar
y si además cuando llega a casa abre la
nevera y se zampa lo que se estampa es
que es hora de comer no te acuestes
de tal manera que estos relojeros tienen
que funcionar de una manera armónica
tienen que funcionar todos a la misma
hora no podemos estar dándole a nuestro
cerebro en el estómago son las dos en el
ejercicio son las cuatro y en el cerebro
central son es las doce y eso es lo que
estamos haciendo
tenemos que volver un poco a la armonía
la verdad que cuando descubres estos
relojes y estos relojeros y cómo están
organizados también te enamoras
yo cuando lo descubrí dejé de ser médico
en realidad sobre lo hero de los relojes
humanos que me encanta es verdad me
encanta porque además estos relojeros
tienen como unos coordinadores jefes
totipotentes están presentes como el
rector de la universidad lo controlan
todo son lo que llamamos genes el ojo
tampoco fueron muy originales entonces
en función de cómo se expresan estos
genes reloj
nosotros nos relacionamos con el tiempo
por ejemplo
y mi gen reloj empieza el día fantástico
y estoy bueno pues yo me levanto trabajo
dicen que soy muy trabajador porque me
levanto muy pronto activo y tal pero
aparte de a partir de la mitad de la
tarde
pero no me hagas irme de fiesta no me
pongas a estudiar a las 11 de la noche
pero si por otro lado
mis genes les cuesta levantar
y me cuesta me voy poniendo me voy
poniendo al final de la tarde estoy
fantástico no hay quien me acueste
tampoco que me levante
unos somos alondras vespertinos y otros
somos búhos y además esto va cambiando
con la edad es curioso los niños
pequeños casi todos son alondras
se llaman tan pronto si contentos
sábados y domingos también
correcto cuando llegamos a esa
enfermedad transitoria neurodegenerativa
que se llama adolescencia
esta historia afortunadamente aunque
cada vez dura más
pues entonces los convertir
[Aplausos]
entonces nos convertimos en búhos
algunos en brazos
y además nos colocamos un cartel aquí un
cartel que pone si me hablas en las dos
primeras horas del día puedes morir
correcto cuando pasamos esa edad
y vamos acumulando juventud yo tengo
bastante juventud está acumulada muy
bien acumulada vale empezamos a ser como
niños volvemos a ser alondras
de tal forma que esto se va modulando
pero esta modulación al mismo tiempo
exige que los relojes de los que
hablamos los relojeros de los que
hablábamos antes funcionen de manera
armónica es decir la primera luz del día
pone en marcha mi reloj central
y el primer bocado e ir andando a la
universidad o al trabajo pone en marcha
el resto de los relojes y tienen que ir
juntos porque han ido juntos durante
miles de millones de años
durante algo más de tres mil millones de
años hemos estado sometidos
aproximadamente a 12 horas de luz la luz
que cambiaba a lo largo del día seguidos
de 12 horas de oscuridad oscuridad que
era más o menos intensa en función de
que la luna estuviera más gorda o más
pequeñita de acuerdo y qué ocurre en las
últimas decenas de años
hace 130 años nació un señor que se
llama thomas edison y nos hizo un regalo
la humanidad impresionante que es la luz
artificial entonces las cosas han
empezado a cambiar ahora ya no estamos
sometidos solo 12 horas a la luz estamos
sometidos más horas a la luz pero además
a esta luz esta luz no tiene ni idea de
qué hora es es blanca y es blanco es
amarilla es amarilla durante todo el
rato que está enchufada con lo cual
empezamos a despistar a nuestro cerebro
nuestro reloj biológico no entiende si
es muy blanca cómo va a ser lo blanca
todo el rato pero es que además esta luz
nos ha permitido porque no sabemos
usarla muy bien estar despiertos muchas
más horas y es horas que antes
dedicábamos al sueño y al descanso es
cierto que cada vez que el ser humano
aprende una nueva actividad aprende a
escribir aprende a hacer cosas le iba
robando poco a poco tiempo el sueño pero
le robábamos 10 minutos aproximadamente
cada 100
y ahora le robamos 20 minutos cada dos
años hemos introducido una velocidad de
robo enorme y esto quizás sea la causa
de que según la agencia española de
medicamentos y productos sanitarios en
ocho años
aumenta un 10% el gasto en hipnóticos
medicamentos para dormir en españa
resulta que entre la población española
de 22 años y 70 el 75 de las mujeres el
25 de los hombres
consumen diagnósticos de manera habitual
y esto no ocurría antes algo estamos
haciendo que no toca de tal manera que
la luz eléctrica que ha sido un regalo
fascinante ha hecho que en estos 130
últimos años
es decir en unos segundos de nuestra
historia como especie hagamos cosas
totalmente diferentes de las que hemos
hecho durante 3800 millones de años
y además pretendemos que el nuestro
organismo se adapte
rápido y perfecto
de tal manera que hemos convertido en la
luz
artificial en el major desorganizador de
nuestros relojes internos
de tal manera que entre el 15 y el 18
por ciento de la población de europa y
de eeuu tiene horarios de trabajo que
van en contra de nuestros ritmos
biológicos y en otras edades por ejemplo
el 42% de los europeos de 9 a 12 años
tienen perfiles en las redes sociales y
todos sabemos a qué hora se usan las
redes sociales
de tal manera que a pesar de que hoy en
día sabemos que el sueño es fundamental
para nuestro rendimiento para envejecer
lentamente para no tener hipertensión
para no ser obeso para no seguir
pertence o
el diabético
a pesar de eso
el 24 2% de los
estudiantes de primaria y secundaria
de valència se duermen al menos tres
veces en clase a la semana según sus
docentes
el 39 por ciento de nuestros
adolescentes van a clase durmiendo menos
de ocho horas y que ocurre cuando
dormimos poco que nuestro cerebro no
puede al día siguiente mantener la
atención de manera continuada
necesitamos acciones más cortas con
tiempo de descanso en medio para poderlo
hacer porque si no lo hacemos así nos
exponemos a más riesgo de errores y de
accidentes laborales o de tráfico uno de
cada tres accidentes de tráfico está
relacionado con este problema de sueño
de tal manera que todos ustedes todos
vosotros yo la gente que está afuera la
que está más fuera la que está más fuera
somos probados de un enorme laboratorio
interdisciplinar multinacional todos los
múltiples que queráis que está
experimentando que ocurre con el déficit
de sueño adquirido de manera velocísima
como antes nunca había ocurrido y el
problema es que lo estamos haciendo de
una manera que si tuviera que pasar un
comité ético no nos lo permitiría porque
no tenemos grupo control salvo pequeñas
sociedades
aisladas
y esto es para pensarlo
para pensarlo
y asustarse para después tomar medidas
se está convirtiendo en un problema de
salud pública y de salud pública y de
salud individual sólo un ejemplo
el eeuu en algunas cosas a pesar de los
dirigentes va por delante
lo tuvieron en cuenta y adaptaron el
inicio del colegio de los institutos
los ritmos biológicos de los
adolescentes con esa medida que han
conseguido a nivel público ahorrar 8,2
billones de dólares en dos años
es importante pero es que además sabemos
que si nosotros a un chico de 12 años le
permitimos hacer una hora al día de
actividad física al aire libre reducimos
un 10% la posibilidad de que este chaval
a los 18 años tenga depresión
todo lo que significa
de tal manera que algo no estamos
haciendo
hemos confundido a veces velocidad de
cambio con calidad hemos utilizado las
herramientas que nos da la tecnología
sin tener en cuenta las herramientas que
nos da nuestra corona biología nosotros
no somos igual en todas las horas del
día y debemos entender como respondemos
en las diferentes obras de tal manera
que
al descanso y al sueño la naturaleza le
dedicaba antes un tercio de nuestras
vidas cuando yo cumpla 80 años aún me
falta cuando yo cumpla 80 años me habré
pasado 30 durmiendo pero hay
determinadas etapas en las que le dedica
más tiempo desde que un niño nace hasta
que llega a la adolescencia le dedica el
50 por ciento del tiempo y porque la
naturaleza no despilfarra nada porque es
básico
para el desarrollo de este
y cuando nosotros tenemos chavales que
llegan a clase con sueño convertidos en
modelos perfectos de yecla escolar todos
sabemos lo que nos pasa cuando venimos
de eeuu aquí no estamos 3 o 4 días
hechos polvo pues gracias a como hacemos
las cosas lo hemos hecho fantástico
todos casi todos nuestros estudiantes
están en el estado de yecla continuo
durante la época escolar y encima les
ponemos las matemáticas a las 8 de la
mañana cuando ellos están en casa y su
cerebro sigue durmiendo
y nos preguntamos cómo es que esto no
funciona
porque tenemos que tener en cuenta
como somos cómo nos relacionamos con
nuestro entronque ambiental no podemos
separarnos tanto de la naturaleza
tenemos que entender que somos productos
de la naturaleza
y estos problemas no nos afectan sólo a
nosotros un ejemplo tonto las
luciérnagas estas cositas de luz
están desapareciendo y por qué porque si
hacemos
una foto
aérea
de europa
veremos que es sólo el 10% de la
superficie de europa no tiene
contaminación lumínica por la noche sólo
el 10% y las luciérnagas para
multiplicarse
necesitan la oscuridad es una tontería
la luciérnaga pero es un escalón es un
eslabón de la cadena ecológica y esto a
la larga nos va a escupir a la cara de
tal manera
qué
la situación
se nos está yendo a las manos pero
todavía tenemos tiempo
mucho tiempo y el primer paso que es el
paso que le invito es hacer una
revolución saludable
esa revolución saludable es simplemente
empezar nos a preguntar cuando hacemos
las cosas no sólo qué hacemos o cuánto
hacemos qué cómo y cuánto como
cuando como si yo como armonizando un
videoblog digestivo cubrirlo
central
estoy jugando a favor de mi salud
si yo hago deporte agua actividad física
de acuerdo con mi reloj central estoy
jugando a mi salud de tal manera que
respetar los ritmos biológicos pensar
que somos relojes andantes que
necesitamos armonía
y pensar en nuestra salud pero no solo
en nuestra salud si nosotros pensamos en
nuestros relojes andantes respetamos el
tiempo que necesitamos de sueño
estamos poniendo cimientos armónicos
para nuestro salud individual
y lo más importante
estamos dejando a nuestras generaciones
futuras una sociedad mucho más justa y
saludable
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias gracias gracias pero
piensen en él cuando mañana por la
mañana gracias